how many people are like do you think
actually
have unplugged from their own own
[ __ ] because it because it happens
to me daily like i had a call earlier
today with a guy and he's you know he's
telling me that you know he wants like
he has approached anxiety he wants to
talk to these tens they're beautiful he
wants to make the approach and i'm like
okay well tell me a bit about yourself
what you doing what do you look like
sort of thing and he's like you know we
get to the optics of attraction it's
like
dudes five foot eleven and he weighs 220
pounds i'm like you're fat he's like no
no i'm not fat i just put on a little
bit of weight i'm like dude no you're
fat i'm a lot taller than you i'm 63 and
i'm 185 and i'm fat yeah well dude like
i'm i'm just under six foot three and
i'm about 220 pounds right now like i'm
fat right now right like i'm normally
looking good around 207 208 i'm like
dude you're fat like let's unplug from
the lies and accept the reality it's
like by the end of the call
most of the time you know when they
start with the lies throughout the call
i know by the end of the call they're
not going to do anything with it because
yeah it's not good enough for them
because it's too much work right well
that's it that's it yeah most people
don't want to put in the work but we
also get me the hot girls give me the
cheat codes and get me the hot girls
give me the i don't mean that's going to
get me laid right give me the vaccine
that's going to get me laid that'll be
the next thing you know somebody will
come up with a [ __ ] vaccine that'll
get you laid
yeah it's uh well but we got to be
grateful for this rich right we got to
be grateful that most people don't put
in the work because then it allows us to
do it and shine out actually just the
other day was having a conversation with
uh with a couple people and someone
who's not totally
not
they're aware of it but they haven't
necessarily decided if they agree with
it and uh and i s and i shared uh could
you imagine if every man was red pill
we'd be ripping each other's heads off
it would be the most barbaric
environment you could imagine right and
so
and often said it's like it's like a
super power right like once you
understand it and then you know how to
harness it and direct it it's it's
essentially a superpower well it's back
to in in empowering yourself right not
being a victim a victim mentality right
i am not a victim because i'm not
sleeping with that 10. i just haven't
[ __ ] put in the
work to do what i need to do to get that
right and so
you know that's where red pill overlies
i i probably have actually been more red
pill aware than i've than i've realized
given myself credit for because i
learned a long time ago
that ma anything i don't have in my life
is because i haven't put in the work
right all these people whining and
complaining about this oppression or
that challenge it's just the excuses are
nauseating so i actually i have a long
time ago i i have that exact same
problem with dealing with that space
because you and i are cut from the same
cloth we're both entrepreneurs we built
something out of thin air you know we
created value employed people
used and and put in place all these
systems and things and you're like me
like i get pissed off when people
complain and they refuse to do the work
or they look for reasons not to do it
it's like well
how bad do you want it man like how bad
do you want it you know that's it that's
it my sister asked for a job recently
and i said um
the job's yours if you can get 50 people
to show up to this event for us next
week
and she just started with the excuses
how would i do that i don't uh no one
listens to me on social i don't and look
i love my sister and so i had a lunch
with her and i'm like look i don't care
about the event
that's not why i gave you that challenge
i gave that challenge
it was a test like you will figure it
out and by the way there's a really easy
way to do it just [ __ ] buy all the
tickets yourself and give them away like
i shouldn't have to give you the answers
you know
like everybody that complains about
something they don't have it's right i
mean they have that work that's the vast
majority of the population out there
thank god because otherwise they're
plugged in even harder than it already
is to succeed that's
that's why when guys like well you know
how do i unplug my friends and how we
spread this information it's like you
don't most people don't want to hear it
no they really don't want to hear and
they don't want to act on it it's like
you know the trauma has to bring them to
it and they have to be willing to want
to level themselves up and do the work
the vast majority of them won't actually
do that they'll just sit back or they'll
point and sputter and make up reasons or
excuses why they shouldn't do it that's
right and i think that's why i get along
and speak so highly of and have such a
respect for pretty much every red pill
guy i've interacted with because they
did not
uh play the victim they can't play the
victim and be red pill well that's
that's a big distinction like that's a
big difference between guys on the
inside and the outside when i'm talking
about guys on the inside i'm talking
about the one percent community that
you're referencing and it's because they
decided to put their money where their
mouth is
they you know they paid the entrance fee
and now they're in there actually
networking doing the work showing up at
the events helping each other out that's
that's why that barrier is there it's
because otherwise it would just be like
any one of these other you know facebook
groups that i mentioned earlier the
league of savage
iron men whatever [ __ ]
you know they're all the same they're
just free groups that people pile into
and then like vomit up their [ __ ] all
day long with nobody actually doing
anything with it or taking any real
steps right that's why you have to have
that barrier like that's why there's
these tears
yeah 100
um
not to change topics but i just saw
miguel's question or comment about now
that he started consuming red pill he
actually has less women
um
and i don't have all the concepts right
so like that to me that's uh that's an
element of the women he would have
gotten wouldn't have been is that in the
live chat or is that a super chat were
you looking for that uh i think he did a
super chat five dollars uh yeah okay
here why don't we do this why don't we
hop into super chats i got some people
ready to ask some questions so alberto
says
how could i have more willpower to
follow through with things like exercise
eating healthy and not waste time on on
any tips for a 29 year old
see i get the willpower question a lot
yeah
um
how do i stop
yeah take it but it's like you know how
do i stop using social media how do i
stop fapping how do i you know have the
willpower to go and push through on
something go ahead man let's see what
your thought is on yeah i would say
you know
first of all motivation comes and goes
right and so being able to do something
when you don't really feel like it
that's what discipline is and willpower
really is
and the the number one thing that i
found that has helped me
is to get serious about my why and
clarity about my why why do i want to do
this why do i want to
eat healthy why do i want to work out
more because if you don't have super
clarity on that
then you've got no destination that
you're going to and you're just
experiencing the short-term pain and and
it's important to remember that there's
discomfort in all choices
right there's discomfort in getting out
of bed early in the morning to get your
[ __ ] done and there's discomfort in
staying in bed the question is are you
going to experience the discomfort now
or later
right so getting to stay in bed you feel
good for you know another hour you're
warm you're cozy but then you're beating
yourself up later in the day right so
you're feeling discomfort and then
you're still fat so when that disease
comes in or you can't do what you want
to do or you're winded or you don't look
good when you approach a woman then
you're feeling pain then so
ever there's pain in all choices so
choosing the pain that's going to move
you closer to your goals but again all
of that comes back again to
what's your why
why do you want to do these things and
if you have clarity on that enough
then you'll often be able to push
through the willpower not always like we
all slip
i know what no one's perfect in their
[ __ ] willpower
have you have you read simon sinek start
start with why or seen his ted talk um
i've seen this ted talk um as it relates
to like business and start with your why
there yeah but you can apply that to
your personal life exactly like you just
described so you know here here's
homework for you now alberto is go on to
youtube or on ted and search for start
with why simon cynic and watch that talk
and he explains it from a business
perspective but the way that
um my colleague here is explaining about
applying to your personal life you just
it's just drag and drop r d stands for
rip off and duplicate right it's not
research and development rip off and
duplicate okay that works over there
let's bring it over here sort of thing
eating healthy is a choice man like
you're talking about something as basic
as willpower like
i find it strange
and maybe it's just me but i i just find
it strange that there's such an
obsession today with nofap
it's like
how do you live your life in such a way
that you just cannot not go without
touching yourself for a frickin day
like why is this such a big
accomplishment for guys today or why is
it such a big talking point you know for
guys today and it's like because they're
[ __ ] right because most guys don't
have
basic fundamental willpower they haven't
been driven
when they were younger right like
my old man rode me like a horse man like
i
i was the firstborn i was up first thing
in the morning didn't matter if i was
hungover as a teenager and i was helping
him in the garden doing whatever it is
he needed done like around the house
because i was i was basically the unpaid
help right
and if i didn't like it then i'd have to
leave right yeah society doesn't value
that anymore right they they value
comfort and right so now in abundance
and so now what does society do to sort
of like make up for that it's like oh
let's let's make nofap a thing like not
touching myself for a day is an
accomplishment not touching myself for
two days is bigger accomplishment for a
week for a month you know sort of thing
and it's like this is like basic [ __ ]
right well whether it's no fap or
whether it's eating well uh eating
healthy or whether it's you know take a
cold shower every day for 30 days to to
start to build discipline these are all
just tools to help jump start this these
discipline routines that so many of us
lack and myself included right but
all of it goes back to
none of it is going to work if you don't
have a why and a shortcut to finding
your why is you answer that question
five times right or four or five times i
want to eat healthy okay why well
because i want to be healthy okay well
why because i want to
look good to get the women i want okay
well why because you and you keep asking
eventually and i'll share my why my why
when i went through this process at the
beginning of last year
was i want to live authentically for my
kids i want to be able to show them what
a man who lives with integrity is not a
man that
bows to every
uh imposition put on him or feels like
you know and actually here's a great
example we had um these backs mandates
come down
and uh and i was pretty upset at one
point about it because i thought i might
have to lose a pretty major contract of
mine
and i realized how can i how could this
be happening for me not not to me right
i realized what a gift i've been given
to be able to live my actual ideals here
if i lose this contract at the end of
the day it's not even make or break for
my life but it's meaningful and what an
opportunity and so i i had such clarity
i was talking to another one percenter
on the phone one morning afterwards i
actually called like three one
percenters to talk to her because it
just the email just came out
but
i had my why
that allowed me to navigate that
challenge right and so
yeah anyway back to willpower finding
your why is the first step if you don't
have your wire you're just loosey-goosey
about it you're gonna crumble every time
some opposition comes up every time you
want to stay in the sheets
hell yeah hey guys i really hope that
you enjoyed that short clip if you did
consider supporting the creation of
content by checking out my supplement
line pinned in the top comment below of
this video in the comments there's a
link to the unpluggedalpha.com forward
slash shop when you click through you'll
be able to land over here and the entire
lineup is broken down by category that
it performs best in estrogen metabolism
fat burning your foundational essentials
for health immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching i
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out
you